okay
for people joining this live stream we
are doing a design review for some
future functionality more from language
related
to interactivity of graphics
so let's get started here
right so this is you know a lot of stuff
that we've had before but
which i don't particularly like let me
let me tell you that i
i personally the fact that there's
dynamics here and the killer
feature of the fact that i get that
dynamic warning when i get a notebook
with these things in it that's killer
and we've got to fix that yep um
but i don't think that that's i mean
that's the notebook issue
well i mean there's stuff it's not we
can
look personally i don't really care
about this little
little whisper of interactivity but i do
care about the fact that it's slow
and it generates that uh dynamic uh
dynamic content warning
kind of making sense so i mean i i will
point out that you haven't hit a dynamic
constant warning yet
that is an interesting point i mean you
very well might by the time we get to
the end of the notebook but
it's not well there we go there we go
so so what why why why that shouldn't
happen
the training chart will be hard to do no
no no
no no no no no trading chart is isn't
look look
listen listen the thing is you need to
work
who's project managing here first
question i'm in charge of this
and then you need to work with john on
the question of how we sign these things
so that if you generated the thing
yourself
it does not come up with a dynamic
warning or
that we carve out some kind of sandbox
for dynamic you know for dynamic
features
that are in our own visualization
capabilities right
and trading chart is
big and old and hasn't been updated you
know with everything
it has and and so i'm aware i'm aware
but what i'm saying is
that the design criterion has to be
that it the best cases
we can sign our own visualization
generated things right that we know we
generated this dynamic content
therefore we can sign it and the front
end can run it without a dynamic warning
am i making sense that's different from
a user-generated dynamic content
which could have all kinds of malicious
stuff in it
right okay so our stuff has to be
signable
and you need to work with john to figure
out how that works
yep okay now
all right so i mean great what what are
you showing here
so the focus of this section was
you know we have had things that have
interactions
right and but we haven't had any control
over them
yeah i know and i'm not that keen on i
mean i better
not they're nothing special and and the
fact that these are default tool tips is
also rather ugly
i mean this is amusing but
um but anyways so but the other part of
it is that
we want the design to be able to
encompass
things that you know these
you know sort of previous iterations
where it was baked in and you had no
control over it
but also this is sort of useful because
it gives us a set of examples of what we
want to aspire to
that of things that we want the design
to be able to cover
um
and and so right this thing here is
important
yep okay
okay so now what am i doing next i i
would click the open button
and it should take you to test and okay
we have people from the cloud team here
right
we have matt john wasn't able to make it
but
um we have matt adams
okay and so now you can open the
this one here what's it doing
okay so so first question is why was
there no preview image there
matt and i were discussing that before
you don't have to look into that i don't
know why there isn't a cache
okay
and so the examples i have here have
a couple of things and a couple of
different methods
uh so one is what i'm calling a ball
highlighter which is
you know it's basically tracking but on
the context
this state isn't good right so i'm i'm
off
the curve but i kind of would still
expect there to be i mean like if i go
to that trading chart for example
right and i go here i've still got
something
even though i'm way off the curve right
and so there's
an example with that farther down
okay but i i think that here
yeah this is very weird what happens
here
okay
is it less weird in this case or
see i might not even know that this had
i don't know i don't know i mean i
i don't know i mean i mean i'm one of
those people who as i'm reading text
will take my mouse and
select things just not
i'm not one of those people um
i'm really not not for any purpose but
so i just
sort of inherently that that's weird
when you have multiple things within the
mouse
domain yeah that's interesting it's not
a crazy thing to do i don't think
it's not crazy but i don't think it
should be the default
um i don't know i'm not sure i don't
know what you do in this case
honestly i think it's less annoying than
picking one and not being able to find
the others
true of not having enough granularity
rather than no i don't quite understand
i mean you know there are clearly other
things you want to be able to do like
like a flag that tells you to coordinate
some things
okay double highlighting slice
skylighting
so i think this is a little bit closer
to
what you were
talking about a minute ago although
there's a compromise here which is
which is to be in the um
[Music]
um
you know so the question is are you
dropping
a vertical or are you picking up a
horizontal here
because either way you could be did you
get what i'm saying if you're doing the
slice thing you could either be
vertical slicing or horizontal slicing
correct
and you could also do both i mean given
this particular point in 2d
it defines you know it defines a double
slice so to speak
that might look too weird i don't know
whether i mean it might look too weird
and i'm not sure if
matt's framework is up to that at the
moment
that's cool what that does that's nice
actually surprisingly useful
the next one is the one that impresses
me because i didn't
specifically aim to do anything for it i
i was expecting this to break
to be honest yeah okay that's nice
um
so this is with the crosshairs why would
we care
i mean unless it has a flag saying what
the coordinates are why would we care
about this one
other than just like it's it's a um you
know it makes it
it makes it twinkle you know it makes it
seem like it isn't completely dead
why isn't it cross-hairing from that
position
i'm not sure
oh i see it only though it crosses from
the
position so it's snapping to the points
and it's cross herring from the position
of the point
right and i think
we need a form that's just complete free
form crosshair
um you mean independent of the points
independent of the points of the curve
or whatever
it's just possibilities
that is labeled and that snaps to points
so i'm saying you get near a point on
the crosshairs snaps right onto the
point
so it's a free form but that snaps when
you get close enough
right let's zoom out a little bit what
are we okay
so we've got these and now what else do
we have here
what is this what is which
oh these things documentation notebooks
so those are documentation notebooks
i've started to write
are they do i need to do a quick cvs
update
okay
okay
right this is interesting so
highlighting is a wrapper like labeling
like labeled or call out or yeah tooltip
et cetera
well but let's just understand i mean i
assume you've looked at
endless other examples so you know what
what else exists out there right
right and there's a lot of stuff out
there and
yeah some of it gets misused and some of
it is used well
and um
okay but i mean in terms of basic
capabilities
this cross-hairing i mean the other
thing i've
seen is is highlighting a curve right
right bolds up right and
we saw that with the parallel axis plots
yes when we were looking at the desktop
i did see that and that's nice and it's
really important there
sure
right i think it's important for all of
these parts
and you know there's a there's a
complicated issue who do we have it we
have people from
ux here because that's relevant right i
don't think we have any ux people
so we should have done yeah because and
i guess for a repeat of this we need
probably
noah path um
i keep forgetting perth is ux now yes
um okay but
but i think what's important here is
kind of the receptive fields
for for these curves
right we need a theory of those do you
understand what i'm saying i mean so in
other words
receptive well i mean the the
hit hit zones whatever ah okay
right you know what roger do you have
comments
on this yeah uh i mean we've done
several but but largely it's sort of the
distance to the curve
which is the shortest path to the curve
are you sure
i mean in other words the issue here is
given given that i'm at this point right
so i've got
i've got several things going on right
let's say i've got
i mean in general we have to think about
you know zero dimensional
one-dimensional two-dimensional etc
structures in a graphic right
and you have got for the time being and
again we don't have people from
from ui group here but you know for the
time being we've got a single point a
mouse position
right and a hovered mouth
position and the question is for the set
of
zero one two dimensional objects
in the picture which ones are thought to
be
related to that mouse position am i
making sense
if you wanted a single thing to light up
why would you not pick the closest one
you might want something on the vertical
direction you might want
you might want something like fine fine
but then you did
that that's okay because you can that's
that's just a constraint
that's saying well i don't know what
that's right where to think about it
because you might want
here you might want the vertically
closest here you might want the
horizontal etosis
you might want that curve to light up i
don't know you might want
a horizontal crosshair except it isn't a
crosshair it's just a horizontal hair
and you know where it where it
intersects with this first
curve or with multiple curves right but
so you know i think there needs to be
okay the point i was going to make is
the the the world
of a single hover point is not
necessarily the world we
the only world we need to support
because there's also multi-touch which
we're not doing much with right now
i don't know how successful multi-touch
has been does anybody know
again we needed this should have been
arranged with ux people here
i mean there's like a whole ipad ecology
and
and smartphones yeah so i would say it's
been successful
well wait wait wait wait pinch zoom is
successful that whole thing is called
multi-touch
i i i look look you know what i'm
talking about multi-touch is not just
pinch zoom
multi-touch is for example it's more
than you have more than one touch
indeed but but for example in you know
some of the touch press
uh you know ebooks right taiyo had
experimented with you know like
10 touch things right
where you have you know like the the
molecules app that he made
you actually can put your fingers down
in many places and it's sensing all of
those places and doing something with
them
okay and they're making sense i i
suspect the case is that
anything more than two-touch breaks down
quickly
because an apple even experimented with
some extended language beyond that i
don't think people remember it
no i agree i agree it's like
three-fingered you know stuff on track
pads and so on is is
is sort of at the limit i think well i
mean i think
what the limit is is not necessarily how
many things are touching
but you know if you have
four fingers on your touch pad
the constraints that that puts on the
motions that your hand can do
i don't entirely buy that i i think that
for example i think
object manipulation see if i can find
one here
see if i have this um
okay let's see
let me see if i can actually do this
hold on one second
uh yeah my analogy is
you know sort of playing twister with
your fingers
um i'm trying to think how i do this i
have an ipad connected to this device
but if i use the sidecar mechanism
uh how can i do this you just trying to
show the screen
i'm trying to share the screen of the
ipad i think you can do it with
quicktime but
i'm not positive
i mean i usually i use the ipad as an
extended desktop
for my main computer
right and so that's um so do you use it
for drawing
no i have a separate thing this
remarkable tablet
which i'm using for drawing i use it i
use it because
i can put it on a something in front of
my main monitors so that i can use it
for video conferencing
that's its main use
that makes any sense understand what i'm
talking about
maybe right because because it is
it is um optionally portable in front of
my main
um computer screens let's see if i can
do this here
um
okay let me see what i've got here
um
so that i can be looking at the ipad
rather than looking off into some
weird direction on the screen right
there we go
incredibly high tech all right let's see
if i can focus
how could it not be focusing crazy
okay well anyway let's go find a
molecule here
um i don't know which molecules
let's see why these now i think
where are they oh actually maybe it
needs to go back to the molecule gallery
no gallery of molecules there we go
can you see this oh gosh it looks
terrible um
the molecules are blown out but we can
see it okay
all right okay
why is that happening let me just think
why is that happening
um
that's not useful
okay hold on i've got a solution for
this
so what's that
i just like that you've got a solution
for everything well i'm going to try
let's see
my idea is if we move this
over here and we put a piece of white
paper there
this is really a hacky solution but you
see what i'm getting better
it's getting better right is there an
ipad above it too
no wait a minute above it that's a
camera that's the camera
the big rectangle yeah the big rectangle
is the camera
okay has a um
okay well whatever i can make the
molecule there
now i've got the molecule um
it's a beautiful molecule okay so now
look at this i've got
i can use well i don't know what what
difference it really makes but my
molecule if
what the heck see see look look look
look
if i take those two can you see that if
i it's it's turning
i don't know why the molecule doesn't
get i guess the molecule just
intrinsically they light up and
they light up but but i can use multiple
touch points here i know why i'd want to
i mean like like here the heck
well maybe that's just a different let's
see if i can get to a different molecule
um
maybe i need a bigger molecule the
multi-touch i haven't
enjoyed the most is a garage band on my
phone i can like play chords on the
keyboard and
it's actually like pretty nice to like
make songs i see
yeah that's a good application i mean
keyboards have had multi-touch
for keyboards like pianos have had
multi-touch for a long time
but okay so this is a case where okay so
i my basic
thesis about this is multi-touch other
than for pinch zoom is a flop
and this doesn't even support pinch zoom
because it's trying to support multi
multi-touch where i can put you know
where i can play some kind of crazy
chord in this molecule
i mean it's it's amusing but i don't
it's
it's getting really active now right
well
um ah
some
okay well in any case yeah i mean i
i think you know the exception to
your you know more than two multi-touch
is a flop
is the exception where
like matt's example with playing a chord
where you're using multi-touch but
overall
it's you know a gross hand movement
you know well no a keyboard is a
one-dimensional thing and our fingers
are arranged sort of one-dimensionally
yes um there are also
the two-dimensional inputs on that you
can like sp
like if you're sort of djing you can
like play a chord and then slide your
finger
and like the x-axis might be uh
repeating the chord and the y-axis might
be a filled audio filter of some sort
and so you can like
slide around artistic okay but dj djing
is the extreme case
of kind of uh you know multi
you know yeah it also takes a long time
for people to learn to play chords and
things you know like on a guitar or a
keyboard
i mean they've spent years on that right
so it's it's it's a skill you don't
immediately have
i don't know chords are not that big a
deal on a you know
i mean well whatever but okay
my point here is the theory of i mean
the theory that we're dealing with here
has to be you know
it's a theory of you have a single point
perhaps two points but probably we're
just dealing with pinch zoom
okay and
but the first order theory is a single
point and then the question is what are
we highlighting
based on you know we hit somewhere we've
got this graphic what do we highlight
right and and so the stuff that they
have in cloud
is sort of very nice for this and in
that
we can say
um basically which axes are we
looking at things in um
and so so where is the design for the
cloud is that the design so this is
where
this is highlighted this is the old
highlighted now that is the old
highlighted a static thing
okay so
so the design for the cloud is
adjacent anything that well i i
understand that you've told me
you had up down here you had these
specific
things here so what you're saying
highlighting include highlighting
i know but i'm looking for the
documentation notebook and it's not um
oh highlighting that's the difference
sorry
highlighted in highlighting that's a bit
obscure
and not probably survivable
it was the name you came up with the
last time we discussed this but okay
names aren't always in flux until they
release and then even then sometimes
okay all right so then we've got
concept here for what
okay so this says this thing is going to
have certain kinds of highlighting so
for example
this might implicitly be wrapped around
every element
every line every point in a graphic yes
correct which is what you know the list
plot examples
are doing in cloud it bliss plot is
you know via the default setting for the
include highlighting option
sort of sneaking in this wrapper as if
it were literally
present
okay um all right
so you've got
okay
so what the heck is this
so it should be sticky okay so these are
these are features
of the highlighting so there's some
you're suggesting there's some kind of
hysteresis type thing
that you hit it once and it always stays
on
as a possible feature so that you know
it's a click
slash tap thing instead of a
mouse over type thing and how do you
turn it off click again
i see
okay um so so for example this is what
um you know the sectors in pie chart too
when they pop in and out
is they maintain a little bit of state
on
whether that effect is active at the
moment
is that variable by a program
i mean isn't it one would expect that to
be some kind of dynamic
some kind of dynamic variable is it it
is
okay but it's an internal one right now
yes
okay i mean it's a dynamic variable that
lives inside that graphic
right as a dynamic module of some kind
yes
okay um
okay so all right
and and so so coming from you know the
top you know we have you know sort of
basic settings are you're giving
essentially a style
in which case that is the highlight
style when you mouse over the elements
um or trigger the elements um
so but that that will be similar to i
mean you know with mouse over
we've clearly got you know
that's a bad example but i mean
you know that's what mouseover is
effectively doing
correct except that what this is doing
is it's saying
that you want to add a
style to that object which would if it
was a
so effectively what that's doing is it's
it's doing
it's like a a function version of mouse
over where it says style
hash comma blah correct yes
okay and this is exactly what
you know if we look at the parallel axis
plot example again
um so
it is using a front end you know
somewhat carefully constructed front-end
constructs
so that you know there's a
was it 100 lines there there's 100 line
primitives
and there's only 100 line primitives
um so we aren't duplicating
the actual primitive we're managing to
just swap in the additional style
right we have all kinds of good comments
and questions on the live stream here
but one that just came in is
is how do you do this one with with the
touch screen i guess what you do is the
same as i was showing with those
molecules i mean
would this work right now if i if i
pulled up this file on the in the cloud
would it work
i mean so parallel access plot gets
bitmap this is this is a
if i did this in the cloud app
i'm not sure i haven't tried it on the
cloud app
um it's an interesting question
i think it's just disabled okay but but
again
well i mean and there's the question
yeah the cloud app versus the
yeah player browser but cloud app versus
the browser versus the player
but but i mean what do we want this to
do presumably
with touch in this particular case
because it is an extended object
touch is a perfectly fine like the
molecules is a perfectly fine thing to
do
you know i'm touching here i've got my
great big finger at this position
here but still there's a big tail to the
animal which you can see
outside of the location of your finger i
mean the problem with the tool tip
with your finger is you've got your
finger there
that's a good point i mean the other
problem with your finger is it's
you know much larger hit area than
um your mouse pointer well right
so it it's a you know in in our theory
of highlighting so to speak we've got
sort of a
we seem to have two kinds of things we
have the point
the zero dimensional mouse pointer and
we have the kind of
the gaussian blob of your finger
both of which is the things we need to
consider i think but
i think clearly highlighting a single
point
in um see even one of these things
this is perfectly viable if there's a if
there's a crosshair
it's perfectly reasonable to use your
finger for hover for the crosshair
right i mean especially that one where
it's only tracking the x position and it
doesn't care what the y value
is well either way i mean
if if if i put my finger here even
though i can't see the thing that i'm
putting my finger on which is kind of
annoying
um i can still see the um uh the things
that it goes to on the axes now
the statement i can't see what's on my
under my finger you know one mechanism
that's used in some apps and that's why
we should have had people from ux here
is that you know you have some kind of
magnifying glass which shows you
uh sort of displaced from your finger
what is under there
like we have for the uh image inspector
indeed indeed i mean if i take that
um
let's see how do i get a nice image oh i
want an image
of um
what's a good animal life
i think it would be better but i'm going
to stick with mine because that's what i
typed in
that's a very small line
okay there we go so now now um uh
all right not so small yeah i wonder why
it came out so small too
um okay so now what you're saying is if
i go to
is it the selection tool is it the pixel
one
yeah there we go right so that's a good
offset that's a good example
of something which we could do for touch
i don't think it would be a crazy thing
to do for touch
for one-dimensional objects
right because sorry zero-dimensional
objects but for one-dimensional objects
there's no reason to do this
and that very might well then cover up
the rest of the thing that you're
trying to look at well i don't know it
wouldn't
cover up the crosshairs look at this one
this is often a quadrant where it's not
going to cover crosshairs
well no what i mean is that if you had a
one-dimensional thing
you know so you had a curve that was
going from the northwest to the
southeast
or that was you know zooming around all
over the place
that something like that would
potentially obscure more than it should
no doubt right but but i think we're not
talking about that i mean we're saying
for the case of touch
with a one-dimensional object like a
curve you just
light up away from your finger
so okay so the the
all right so let's just look back at
your
i mean
okay so this is the appearance
so so these are sort of named
appearances it's essentially a
collection of
fine-grained thing things
yeah but okay so what's the general
version of this the general version of
this
is presumably a function applied to the
graphics object
that you are currently indicating
look there are two things the two things
okay you touch somewhere
something isn't has now been you know
something has now been touched
it might be a line it might be three
lines it might be a point it might be a
bunch of other things
okay once touched what does it do
it jumps up and flaps its arms around
and turns
green or something right in other words
a function is applied to it so you have
found that graph experiment somehow you
are touching that graphics primitive
and now you and now you say what's going
to happen to that graphics protip
so first question is which graph
experiment is you touching
second question what do they do when you
touch them
now actually there's a third point which
is
it's not just a question of touching
graphics primitives it's a question of
where you touch them so for example in
the case of a line
it can matter that i'm going over here
and
i'm you know that's the line boy this is
complicated
this is complicated because because i
don't think we can factor it into what
did you touch and what does it do
do you understand what i'm saying so
right because in this case the what
um roger do you have any thoughts about
this
i i think that the the function applied
to
to a whole graphics
thing is
uh complicated
i i was just going to say i mean i like
having function forms of things as much
as the next i don't know no no i don't
think you were
were you look no i understand what you
were saying
we've got several different things okay
you are touching this graphic somewhere
right
what elements of the graphic care about
you doing that like like for example
here
if i might you know if i'm here right
the points over on this side they just
don't care
they're not being activated they're not
being tickled by what i'm doing
do you see what i'm saying so first
question is which things
like like for instance here or wherever
you have one which has
where do you have one which is lighting
up a whole line i
don't think i included anywhere it's
lighting up the whole world so so we
know
we know in in the case of something like
this we're lighting up the whole line
right yes okay so but the question of
what doesn't care about what you're
doing
right we could it could be that as soon
as we touch here
everything lights up right so first
question is
what's the selection of what what cares
about the fact you're touching
in the position you're touching so
we can think about that in a couple of
different ways we can think about
the place where you're touching kind of
radiating a field outwards
or we can think about and then seeing
what does it
i mean i i just don't quite know how to
think about it whether whether it's
better to attach
and i'm being touched you know
indication to a particular element of
the
of the graphic or whether it's better to
start from the toucher
so to speak and sort of radiate some
field outwards
do you see what i'm saying i think my
answer is that
those are both good things and they are
separate things
okay and i mean and this is
you know what the cloud examples have
um for example where for some of those
you know where it's using what i'm
calling the ball highlighter
it's highlighting the thing that you're
touching
for the ones where it's the slice
highlighter it is
radiating out in the examples in the
notebook
in a vertical you know direction right
so you you have yet a third concept
okay your concept is you have a certain
highlighting tool
a slice of ball whatever else
and that
tool i see it's it's your kind of hyper
finger
in some sense your hyper mouse in the
sense that
instead of it being just a single point
with the mouse as soon as you're using
the slice
tool you have extended what your
you know you've extended your your
mousiness so to speak to that whole
uh you know one dimensional line right
and if you look at the trading chart
example
it's even going across the different
panels i know
yeah i know um
i mean one thing that i did before we
did thought experiments like what if
this was in 3d
then we would have dropped planes for
instance instead of dropping lines
yep yeah so things generalize in some
ways
but then there might be like in this
case you only drop down by one dimension
but you might want to drop down by two
dimensions in 3d
down to a point yeah
i wasn't going to bring up the 3d stuff
yet because i think we're still not we
still don't have the right calculus
for the 2d case of you know one thing to
do is think about it in terms
okay so we've got these different things
a generalized notion of touching
with what does that do to an object
you're proposing a different theory
in which the touching
device
is itself a non-trivial thing you know
the hyper mouse
is a vertical slicer
for example i mean in some ways it
almost sort of reminds me of
like with a 3d graphic how you hold down
the modifier keys and it changes what
the
you know mouse click behavior is
so um
i don't think that's right i don't think
you have the right kind of model here
i mean look
i think um
you know one model is you've got slicers
and pointers which are basically the
the one-dimensional case in the
zero-dimensional case
you could also have potentially a
two-dimensional
you know you could have the the the
large circle you could have something
you know i could imagine something
it's not necessarily a good idea where
when i touch here
a whole circle of stuff within some
radius lights up
see what i'm saying kind of like a
magnifier
yeah kind of like a magnifier maybe
except the magnifier will
will displace the objects but it would
be like a um
uh well it's like a highlighter really i
mean
like a like a you know like a you know
one of those yellow highlighting pens
you
you're you you don't highlight with a
highlighter pen
you're highlighting regions not you know
it's unlikely
you would notice a highlighted point
so now the other thing that here is
to just confuse you but it's super
super powerful the best way i know to
highlight is to de-highlight
it's the same effects you know some
people sort of shout louder to emphasize
their point
some people go lower and so
de-highlighting is very
efficient well um i don't know what that
i mean it only works if it's dynamic
i don't know what do you mean by that
well if it's highlighted and it's and
it's disappeared
then you just don't know it's there but
if you if you are no i mean it doesn't
have to go away all the way it can just
you know b like let's say let's say that
you were on that curve that you're on
there right now
let's say that all the other ones went
gray
yeah okay fine yes that's a good point
right so that's
that okay so i understand what you're
saying so that's a that's a global
that's not so for instance for graphs we
use
you know d highlighting is is probably
the most effective way of highlighting
right okay let's come back to this for a
second
um
i'm telling you we need some kind of you
know i mean this is kind of like the
model view controller of highlighting or
something
it's it's like how do you factor these
different pieces
so that we can understand what's going
on
um yeah i mean what you've got but
you're flexible do you want to be with a
model
that's the question i don't know i don't
know and i mean it could be that in the
end
once we have the model there are only
five cases anybody cares about we just
give them names
right but i want to understand whether
there is a model
because that way if we have such a model
then
you know when we have region value geo
region value plot or something
we can expect that we can immediately
generalize to that
um let's look at some of the comments on
our live stream and then
i i feel like we have the wrong people
in this meeting we should have had ux
people we should have had graphic design
people um okay not the right meeting
uh but um let's take a look at some of
these comments and then let's
shed another one of these i mean i'm now
you know we've now introduced this thing
i'm impressed by what i'm seeing in the
cloud there particularly
um uh
well done on that um
okay let's see sander is commenting
snapping to points being able to read
the coordinates would be good yes
but i mean that you know that relates to
a thing that you might want which i
don't think you have here which i think
is an obvious thing
is a is a flag so it's essentially a
tool tip
which might be content related related
to this point
like it might be that in a feature space
plot by the way brett
by the way did you get my mail again i i
looked at it i think it's a simple book
it's a bug
i think so oh for goodness sake we'll
see if you can fix it
super annoying and um machine learning
claims they've reported it multiple
times but and they feel it
i looked at the bug reports last night
and
i didn't see anything that looked like
what i was seeing as a bug
okay fine but then what we're talking
about is that in feature space plot
you should be able to say um
you know thing arrow red thing arrow
green etc
and those reds and greens should be the
ways that the things are rendered in the
feature space plot correct
yes okay but that's not happening right
now
that's not what you were doing i mean
that's not what that example was doing
so so maybe there was an example that
you tried
that didn't work at all no no look look
what i'm saying is
you've got feature space plot look i
mean that we can we can do a simple
example here
okay so let's say we say table i goes to
red
i goes to 10 20 let's say
um and then join that with
table don't you love this oh no why
didn't that work
why didn't that work okay that's
something
is that the type through fail it's a
type through fail
this should work this case should work
this case is anybody or am i sending
this message i'm sending this message
um this is a special case the case of
the end of the line like that
is um ah oh this is amusing
my mouse has turned to nothing okay
um as you can see we can see it okay
well
at least some of the time i don't
okay in any case this here
[Music]
um
okay fine now i take that and i say
feature space plot
and that worked
so why didn't it work
i did the same thing with molecules
there
right so it didn't auto it didn't know
how to auto
render molecules i know but but but here
the whole point is the right hand side
is telling it
how to render it right
right but it didn't work with molecules
so if i say
if i say you know control equals i don't
know
let's actually just do this let's say a
random entity chemical
20. okay and now i say molecule of that
of a goodness sake why is this so slow
and this is not dealing with polymers
correctly
okay this is super painful um
okay in any case here we go it's
molecules and what i was trying to do
here
let me um is i said molecule arrow
red for example thread this thing
[Music]
okay and then i'm going to pick a few
other molecules here
and i'm going to say
you see what i'm doing here and then
flatten the whole thing and
feature space plotted
okay okay
that is interesting okay so you think
it's a bug
i think then just go fix it yeah
okay so that that's the thing that i'm
reporting right
right it's supposed to be the case that
the right hand side gives you the
rendering
and it should give you the rendering
even if if you've given explicit right
hand sides
it should be a lot more a lot
laxa in when it decides to abandon
rendering
the objects do you get what i'm saying
because when it gets too big it's going
to stop you know showing all the little
images or whatever else but i think if
you've
given an explicit right hand side and by
the way if the right hand side is like a
color
then you should notice that and you
should keep rendering forever
because you know a color is a zero
dimensional thing and you'll never
run out of space so to speak right
yes so that's another thing that should
should get taken care of anyway and
i the completely separate thing having
nothing to do with you but the feature
extractors for molecules are doing crazy
things
i mean we just added a lot of fancy
feature extractors for molecules that
should
place them so i mean maybe maybe it's
just i don't know my molecules well
enough but i thought i was trying
different
classes of molecules that should have
been separated but they were somewhat
separated
okay uh other vector comments
um
points to show the y values so so i mean
i agree that in cases like this
being able to actually displaying the
values here
would be very nice
i mean there's really it's like some of
our other graphics things
there's a question of uh you know when
does it get too much when does it go
wait wait
why i've resized it okay when does it
get to be too noisy and too annoying and
you know i just wanted to
trace these curves i didn't want to see
these numbers to seven digits and so on
right i also would like to comment that
those numbers like tick labels
need to have the ability to say pi over
three and things like this
see what i'm saying that the absolute
position on the plot may not be good
enough
and for example for date list plot
you're going to need the date displayed
right um
i think one you know common approach i
mean and this is you know another axis
essentially is sort of where does that
label get placed
is it there at the mouse thing is it's
you know along the
you know projected onto the axis
is it projected to the edge of the
graphic i'm sorry which thing the the
a thing like a coordinate or something
yeah right i mean you could have
something where there is simply a little
counter here that gives you the
coordinate values or you could have
something that's hanging
like a flag off the actual point or you
could have something that's at the ends
of the crosshair
right all of those are not unreasonable
um there's a comment from ali here about
show becoming slow with multiple mesh
objects i think we have the wrong set of
people here to discuss that
uh an example go ahead roger do you want
to say something about that
roger like he's not here anymore he may
have had an appointment at five
or after five you know what guys don't
set up meetings like this with the wrong
people on them please
but yeah i i can't say anything about
show and mesh objects
so okay sandra is asking about a scaled
0.1
for snapping horizontal closest vertical
closest distance closest yeah
right i mean there's a there's a
snapping distance
for so that's another you know that's
the question of is it associated with
the object
or with the toucher so to speak for
example an object could say
i would this is another case you know
something could say i'm a very important
object in the graphic let me
let me get excited by touches that are
even
far away see what i'm saying
so that that's a a waiting for well
you know so the basic claim is
it takes you know
two to kind of activate that is the
toucher
and the touch so to speak
the thing that is you know the pointer
whatever it is and the thing that the
pointer is pointing to
and that somehow we need some sort of
calculus of how
um you know of of what the pointer
points at
and what lets itself be pointed at
right because i mean there are certainly
cases where
and you may have elements that you want
to be completely immune to
interactions you know that you're trying
to draw
well that's a good point too so that's a
never point at me thing you know i'm
invisible to you
right right that's a good point now
is is i hope somebody is taking notes
here
it's recorded so okay you're going to
somebody's some project manager is
actually going to go through this with
the project manager
also notes oh thank you personally i
forgot we had andrea
that's good the um
okay let's see uh
lots more comments here um
how does highlighting work with tool
tips
hmm i don't i didn't include it with any
of the examples but
i mean they're mostly orthogonal things
i mean up until the point where we get
into the
things where the highlighter is trying
to show
textual labels or the little zoom
off to the corner that's going to be a
mess
i mean if the highlighter
right what is the difference between a
tool tip
and a flagged highlighting so to speak i
mean analogous to the the thing we had
there with our
our our um
how did i get this again oh was it this
yes there we go
this thing right right but one feature
of this is this is
a from the graphic interpretation so to
speak it is not
a separate piece of information added i
mean a tooltip
is separate metadata that's been added
at some particular position whereas this
is
merely a magnification of the graphic
that is already there
so i think that's the difference in
concept between highlighting and tool
tipping
right tool tipping is adding new
information highlighting is simply
doing something generic it's like a
function the highlighting function
which is applied to different inputs
whereas tool tipping
generally is every tool tip has to be
defined
on its own if that makes sense something
like
date would fall out of side of the
outside of that framework right because
the graphic itself doesn't know anything
it doesn't have a concept of dates
but you would want to well no that's not
correct because the graphic
the graphic knows absolute times and
the translation from absolute times
which is the coordinate position
to the you know display date
is merely is a const is a function that
is independent of position
sure so it doesn't have to be encoded
directly in the graphic it's something
that
that can take what's in the graphic and
transform to what you see
whereas a tooltip for every point in the
graphic needs new information
to say what it does true
so i think that's the way to think about
those um
okay craig is saying use attached cell
to pick the highlighting
that's a good idea yeah it's a
reasonable idea
interesting idea
i mean particularly being able to
the problem is it's going to get very
complicated very quickly
and you know we're going to have to
define and probably it'll be in the plot
theme
which of several highlighting schemes
will be the obvious ones to pick up for
a particular graphic
um yeah and themes is one of the places
where
i mean that absolutely you know should i
mean we'll need highlighting themes
basically feature themes um
static no i i understand right i mean
that that's a feature like for
uh you know i think we're we're going to
redo these plot themes to somewhat
different names but the ones that are
for
you know publications of various kinds
it's not going to be you know
that the dead tree journal doesn't get
to have
uh interactive whatevers and it's in its
graphics
um i mean that's an interesting question
i mean because
you know everybody you know does their
you know puts their pdfs on your
preprint servers
and pdf you may still have some
things that might be interesting i mean
in terms of being able to you know maybe
turn things i've never seen
i've never ever seen that work maybe
other people have maybe i just don't
read
enough academic things but but um i've
i've literally never
seen an active pdf that does anything
beyond
light up its hyperlinks on
on you know preprint i mean servers
possibly um no i know it's possible but
i'm just um
well no i mean you know pdf is
you know a rich language but that
doesn't mean that everybody
you know or maybe anybody outside of
adobe or whatever uses
the full extent of it indeed um
i will tell i could tell the story about
the the bug in pdf that we found when we
were printing the nks book
in 2002 if you haven't heard that story
it's a good story
the which involved some holiday weekend
that involved
me getting hold of i think it was john
warnock
um who was like and getting hold of the
people who'd produced some
direct-to-plate printing device
and it was a bug in postscript been
there for 10 years
it was a bug in the image operator and
nobody had ever tried to do
this um uh
it was a you know a bug that you would
that you saw in cellular automata
type images but not of photograph type
images
anyway it's a too long a story for right
now
um comment from what there could be
handles that appear at the end of
crosshairs to allow altering
boy i don't know i don't know how you
get there
that's what i was just thinking that you
know the crosshairs are so ephemeral
that
you're trying to well that's another
issue right there's another issue which
is
you could imagine a right click that
locks the crosshairs
let's imagine you want to compare
multiple points in a graphic
having a right click to to lock
different you know to
to leave kind of crosshair droppings all
over the graphic
might be very useful
this reminds me a little bit of like the
support lines you see on
stock charts sometimes
where you know they draw a line under
you know with a particular slope under
some section of the
curve um of their stock charts
um right well i mean also that
right
okay let's see that would be a good
thing for mobile too
you scroll and then you pick your i mean
scroll pick your finger up
even and then the drop button stays
there you can see it without your finger
block that's true but how would you get
that i mean you could do a hard press
another one of those things that hasn't
really caught on
or you could just have that be the
default like as soon as you start
before you interact with the graphic
there's no drop lines then as soon as
you start touch the graphic then drop
lines appear and then they're just
i don't think that will work how do you
clear them
uh maybe tap again or tap away from it
yeah i don't think that will work
and then it drops a different crosshair
yes right
if you missed it we'll drop a different
one um
no i think i mean does hard press work
for anything other than maybe
variant keyboard type stuff
or long press or whatever it is what is
that thing anyway
use it for copy paste on ios
oh yeah that's right
okay and i think in the
uh wolfram player app it's in the file
view it changes from
open to select
okay let's see santa says could be plot
legends showing the values
yeah i mean i think that that's all i
mean it's gonna say that introduces a
whole another set of interactions which
are
you know sort of distance from afar well
right
i mean that that yes right that's a
different thing you mouse over the plot
legend
it lights up that curve
or in a more extreme case you've got
a density plot with a legend that shows
different colors
and as you go to that position in the
color scale
it lights up some region inside the
density plot
i'm going to pretend i didn't hear that
well it's also unclear
what what what range of values it should
light
up it can depend on how thick your
finger is or something at that point
okay okay uh
let's see marco um
right you have to highlight features of
plot the system of coordinates and stop
the closest
by selecting some metric
oh boy that's an interesting idea okay
so the micro is suggesting
you could also have gestures to for
example select a line instead of a
single point
so like you move over the line and it
shows a point
but then you start to follow the line
and it shows the whole line
yeah i think the idea would be
i mean that's the thing we have not
discussed is the possibility of gestures
extruding for example just as we talked
about
a a point-wise you know toucher
you could have a line-wise toucher that
you get by essentially putting your
finger or the mouse down somewhere
and moving i don't know this would work
i mean
you you could imagine a thing where it
indicates this
and then you're moving sideways
i don't know i mean where there's some
gesture that generates a larger
um you know generating your interaction
region
around them possibly yes
all right craig here shouldn't
highlighting accept a distance function
for nearest yaya yes well that's what
we're talking about here yeah
we could compile the distance function
and we could do that i agree
right i mean the thing is that you don't
necessarily want the distance function
to be in the
graphic coordinate system i mean it
wants to be i think in most cases in
you know like a points well that's an
interesting question in its own right
in 3d it's going to get much more
complicated with that
but in 2d
is it the case
you're claiming it's always in the
screen coordinate system that's all you
ever care about
i am claiming that that's what you will
99 of the time once that
if it's an actual distance function in
cartesian space
that okay so let me let me let me
horrify you for a second
remember axes objects that we're just
putting in right never heard of them
i think you've done them a lot okay so
access object
and um uh you know the fact that you can
have spiral axis objects for example
strongly suggests that you should be
able to have spiral crosshairs too
in other words what we're looking at is
not polar plots where should the
crosshairs go on a polar plot
i mean they should probably well okay i
mean in general polar plot has
access to both worlds i know but should
there be radial
should there be radial crosshairs in a
polar plot
i think there's a good argument for that
as you go around you know radar plot for
example let's say that that's an example
of a
you know you don't really want
rectilinear crosshairs on a radar plot
and imagine rectilinear cross says on a
pie chart
they're pretty stupid and imaginable
or when we had ternary plots well yes
your crosshairs are going to be
little three direction things
right but imagine a think about the case
of a pie chart
where there's really a lot of pie wedges
in the pie chart
okay so so let's imagine that we say you
know pie chart
range of 50 or something
okay so over here well actually look at
that you've got radial
i mean you've got basically radial cross
airlines there
i mean yeah there's edges on the sectors
but yeah i know that edges on the
sectors but i mean
in if if you were doing something where
you were flagging characteristics of
each sector
you would want radial lines going out
here within each
sector somehow not quite sure but this
is
you know so i think in a sense there
should be
from what we've learned from um
uh from axes by the way it really is
confusing to me
that those drop lines effectively don't
come up
when you're in the white space above the
above here
that i just find that really confusing
i i just think it should drop down to
this by default
um i think it's too fragile when it's
like oh how far away can i go
well i can go that distance away
uh steve is commenting should be able to
click the graph and get a cell added by
the snapped x
y values
yes well that's a question of a right
click menu
that gives you the coordinates and we
should have that i mean just like we
have that
in um i mean we have it it's just
you know nobody you know it doesn't it's
not exposed well enough and
you know that comes back to ux stuff but
well but but i i think one thing we
don't have which is kind of crazy that
we don't have
is if i say you know um
if i do this why don't we have something
it says double click to edit
but why not oh look at that we have get
coordinates and i didn't even know it
there it is get coordinates no where
does it put the coordinates
okay so it didn't actually get the
coordinates i think
what does it do next
and now move back over the graphic
and now if you click it's going to drop
a point
and now you can command c command v out
of the graphic
i mean command c move out of the graphic
why is it why does it why does it say
get coordinates if that's not what it's
doing
yes i didn't know it was there either it
seems wrong
i mean that would be more like show
coordinates
i have a feeling that it got into that
menu as some kind of
uh transfer from some other menu where
it does actually mean this
that that's the thing i i
because i think you know the
functionality in graphics
as i've always known it since version
six
is i get to it through touching
your hitting period with the graphic
selected
and then doing the selecting
and then copying well anyway this is
something for noah for andrea that
this is the thing um
to comment to tell him about because
he's been the one working on drawing
tools
um anyway that seems like a good thing
to to be able to do
uh shift drag to zoom within the plot
yeah we're very well aware of that issue
and i don't know what is that part of
that that's not really part of it
i don't think that's quite part of this
although it touches on
you know sort of the multi-touch side of
things again because
that's a common ah sandra is commenting
the snapping distance viewing distance
or coordinate
distance yeah well that's that's a
really that's the point we're talking
about and
whether you want polar coordinates and
so on which i'm claiming you do
eventually
um i mean and i think for sure you do
eventually want polar and you want the
appropriate thing for ternary and
um probably appropriate things for
geographics that it's tracing out
latitude and longitude and some weird
projections oh that's right
yeah we'll need to do that right the the
the
the lines should not be straight lines
that'll be completely stupid on the
earth
you know in a projection you know yes
that'll be completely stupid they have
to be
uh that long lines
um okay
ali is commenting about 3d graphics uh
you know there's been a bunch of under
the hood changes which actually i'm
wondering if we're even
remembered to include in the 12.3 new in
stuff um there's a there's a bunch of
changes
to do with on different platforms very
platform dependent
and it depends what platform you're on
what's happening i think there are some
new changes on windows particularly
uh okay right windows got its
drawing layers you know took a big step
forward in terms of what we're using
right um
okay i don't remember if i saw it in
your ali is asking
3d graphics be temporarily down sampled
so rotational movement is more fluid
i mean that's obviously what happens in
the cloud and that's a good question
that's a good question we've never done
that for the desktop
i that's a good question
i mean i don't i mean i think you know
there were suggestions around
you know v6 era that we could do this
and
i i forget who was opposed
um well it shouldn't be necessary
exactly ideally it wouldn't be necessary
but i mean for a couple indicated enough
graphic
i mean it can be um
i mean there's times where you know even
the cloud version of i'm just going to
show you the box
and no contents
right it could be a better user
experience than
well that's what we did in version one
uh well it pretty much didn't version
one
that just showed the box for 3d graphics
we had a thing which was
where you just rotated the box and when
you pressed go
it re-rendered the graphic with that
viewpoint it was a viewpoint
selector
i thought rotating 3d graphics was new
in six
that there was what was it like the
real-time 3d package prior to that that
oh no no that had been for version from
version one
there was a thing where you could
effectively pick your viewpoint
by taking something which was a pure box
with nothing in it
and rotating the box to the angle you
wanted and then pressing go and it would
re-render the graphic
oh maybe i do remember this it's been a
few years
indeed um i haven't thought about that
in 30 something years so it's good that
neuron is still alive
um okay i need to run off here let's see
okay i'll do the
comment from arc here the mouse single
click selects the graphic double click
fixes the crosshairs double click but
you have to hold and drag the second
click extends the highlight area
that's interesting there's a whole
language we could make for that that's
an interesting point the double click
can do something different
um i mean doubleclick already does
something
different because it starts selecting
the contents
and so if double click you did different
things depending on whether you hit
white space or not that might be
and steve is asking about coordinates
for maps
and i don't know what it does what does
it do in geographics does it correctly
uh get the light long yes
you get long in two different forms and
you get the
grid position in
sort of what the raw underlying
coordinate system is
what am i about to get here why is this
so slow okay
so you're saying if i do my get
coordinates here
oh look at that that long amazing
it's what like in decimal and dms forms
and
and then you get x and y as the
projected coordinate system
yeah the geogrid position cool that's
cool and so i can select those points
and i can say command c and what do i
get
now a geo position or i guess a bunch of
jobs oh wow
very nice we should advertise that
feature i didn't know that worked
um okay
all right well uh please schedule
another one of these
with the right people in it and again
uh lots of very interesting stuff here
thanks to you guys and thanks to folks
on live stream lots of good comments
much appreciated
all right i've got to go off here uh